would be a good
as the development of 50 dwelling
associated roads sewers gardens
barking and garages and land between old
canals the north side of primrose
i have amended that description of the
development removing things like
resistance
foreign
yeah
mr jeremy
expected later okay
and this is the limitation of the
english language
this missus
sometimes so when we reach the topic of
pyrocycle that can shuttle people around
does necessarily otherwise it's not the
new dream control
on anything
then the council again the limitation of
the english language
in etiquette because i asked this is
this
yes sir
assistance rather than participate in
the yourself thank you very much
i'll have three other people on my list
essentially related to the owners
family
christmas mrs
thank you
and then the uh
local residence which if i just passed
this down if you would mind completing
your details on it
and then if you wish to participate
anyone here from the press
anyone intend to record today's events
other than the live stream we have
running at the back of the motorcycle
okay thank you
notification letters i've got a copy of
the castle notification let's just
appeal for the date time location
hearing
[Music]
rather than have any discussion outside
where something will just imagine for me
to take notes so before we leave make
sure you've had everything
said that you want to say if you want me
to load anything out on site please be
aware of batteries and make sure that
it's
easy to work
we'll be discussing conditions today
that is just standard procedure it
doesn't affect anyone's case anyone's
position it doesn't suggest that i've
already reached a decision
to practice
costs i'm not inviting applications for
costs already to be made they should be
made before the site visit
in addition i have the power to initiate
the water costs whether or not any
applications have been
made by the parties if i were to do this
would follow the written process with
the relevant party actual decision
is issued
so we run on to the other preliminary
matters i've got plans which i received
and revised statements of common ground
about the latest property common ground
right
yes please
is
is
and the planning policy i've got simply
the
northeast establish a local plan in
particular obviously ss1
and lc193
they refer to in the decision notice
respect policies and the consistency of
the national council framework
[Music]
thank
to actually
yes
anything else anyone wants to race
before i move into the main issues
so the main issue
absolutely got two main issues which
won't surprise anyone that's actually
what was on the decision notice the
effect of the character appearance of
the area there's some
issues there derives from that and
of
then
pick up various other matters as well
but please do
if i am moving on before you've had your
say a particular topic please raise your
hand and i'll come back to you
um
is
[Music]
saying that if it's
not within approximately
if there is discussion in the um
policy at reference country at 7.3
um to having identified
what filing permission was previously
the answer is probably this planning
commission previously been applied for
been granted
whatever reasons
and i think the best answer is
[Music]
the purpose of staging that figure
within that policy
um
[Music]
which is
oh
and one thing that uh these excitements
have
said so far is that
the application that's being considered
now
is on
a smaller plot of land
80 percent of the original one that was
granted for 30 properties
they're now wanting to put
20 additional properties on a smaller
plot of land
so if they will be more densely
closely
compact
i think 50 into
80 of what was previously put there and
that that information was just worked
out through looking at on the
information in the original 30 property
um
um
is
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
so the purpose of including that figure
that relates to the overall cameras in
latin supply in that location
period
um
if that figure was absent
just demonstrate that you're able to
achieve the housing
um
you have to have some ideas
only
um
is
particularly changed in its size
okay
thank you
[Music]
uh and that's about those original 30
buildings were for the full size as it
was originally allocated
the proposal that's coming is for a
smaller
uh portion of land
uh with 50 on it and it's in our
representation that that represents
something like a 66 percent increase
if you added what uh the rest of the
tech wasn't able to deal with that you
may be looking at something like 15 20
hours if you were to add that onto it
it's not 66
increase it's something like that you
can increase something in the region of
that now we know there's no proposal in
it there but there's the the way it's
set out there's rooms left there as if
it were to be applied for this one
that's not a subject here we'll be
discussing understand that but if you
look at
the actual density it's not we're not
moving from the third into the fifth day
it's it's uh it's much more than that
because of that other piece of work
that's not being built so that's the
only thing i've punched out there when
we're using the approximate on page 16
lc1 it mentions their approximate
capacity within the plan period if you
look further on uh in kl3 5.3 patients
there's no mention over approximately uh
this site is located to the norfolk
marsh uh 2.87 uh
pictures in size and is expected to
deliver 30 volumes within the first 10
years
there's no approximate there yeah
there's an approximate early on it's in
that table but not in the main right
yes
um
um
is
[Music]
is
is
were agreeing
for the difference between the size
we are all finished on lc one and move
on to
religion further discussion densities in
the line of life
policy ss1 then particularly
gh anonymous or essentially which
migrating
at the time
is
in a sensitive um
uh to settlement edge
that's a non-destinative site
there are services for restoration
space
but we are we are talking about
screening for example
the area um
is
and the greens
sure
yes
inside this
okay
um
okay
um
this
upside down
exists
[Music]
[Music]
then
[Music]
disability
[Music]
discussion about traffic and actual road
access right just about this time
the the smaller site
i think they've touched away from
further away from the canal
and because of sensitive areas on the
canal which might will need remedy
either remedial treatment or a newt i
know it's in the plan
and they actually want to go there
rather than where they
they used to be and
but as for the site layout
i have no particular
so
perhaps the only common type of i think
in our submission
a plan which shows uh exactly what the
site layout is compared to what was
before
that slight widening and uh
myself when you look at it i think
anybody can clearly say it's a
substantial amount that's being put off
it is substantial i think we've got that
in our uh so even to the actual layout
that's nice suggestions
um
at the end of
is
is going to severely impact all
residents on primrose lane from number
70
to the very end especially i think 19
and 21 which will be directly affected
by the access onto the site
they currently have no off street
well i think one has austrian park
equipped to one vehicle
otherwise they all have to park hong
kong's lane
they are made of parts but
the existing primrose lane
not many
is
um well
the starting point is
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
um
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
which is
[Music]
is
on both
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
attention
left
is
[Music]
[Music]
i think that's uh he's
he's not it's not a fair comment uh if
you can go back to that and he thought
something what miss great said uh we did
agree uh that's a local plan here and it
was uh it's in that submission on fish
51 councilman lander and sanders stims
coming
uh when we look at density if you look
in our submission on page 10 10.2 to
10.3 describes it virtually the answer
to that comment made but particularly
one part
that when we're
deciding and looking at density that we
find acceptable as a member of the
planning committee we do use successful
places our document and we use that as
the doctor's planning guidance so that's
what we look at and it states in there
uh paragraph 3.6.7
uh it states that density should
normally be reduced towards the areas of
lesser activity with lower density among
green corridors towards settlement edges
and against the constructors where they
graduated transition between town and
confession so i didn't want to read the
whole lot because that in particular
that's how we arrived at our decision we
came to looking at this
you know just a little bit further there
was no
uh
massive objections of 30 houses being
developed within this area it's it's the
number
that's
[Music]
successful places
um
um
particularly access being provided
is
not
is
on this question of the greenfield site
and
the aspect of wildlife which is
built on will destroy the habitat of
plenty of other things
small rodents and things like that
small rodents welcoming
or things like talks and things lined up
you're going to destroy it
you're going to end up with boxes the
urban box getting all over these houses
and then people say bro
you know we don't want this
well you've got it and if you don't
build on green build sites you're going
to get this and the other thing is it's
a greenfield site
and in this country at the moment we
haven't got enough food production to
keep us goal fed and we carry on what's
going on in ukraine and russia is going
to get a lot worse and we have to
utilize every acre for food production
it's publicly relevant to this we make
it but it is not
just a field
it's there to produce food
i'll be quite honest no refined
the built development to the open space
and in particular we must talk a little
bit more about which label
to be clear on my mind the relationship
from like the front of the houses
through to the canal both as it is now
and how
phasing potentially we don't know or
have exact uh commitment to when that
now might be
restored
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
so essentially i'm starting my house
number
13 viewer
looking at what am i looking out for
various other things behind that and
then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
that would
ensure
oh
denser
[Music]
[Music]
not quite
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
mentioned earlier about successful
places and that case will pause
is
thank you david it's only a very quick
point yeah uh
uh there was some influence that perhaps
how our documents uh and policy
successful places might be out today but
it's not out of date
um
[Music]
my
okay
one of the other points raised by this
in particular blackstock design point of
view was the
described as a long row first of all
five bed
[Music]
[Music]
is
any of the particular balance
respectively
is
um
i have questions and an observation if
i'm late uh the reference to having a
maintenance
company or contractor on-site to
the hedges
does this suggest that the properties
will be leasehold of intelligence
and would the maintenance company be
requested to do with the gentleman did
not weave that is on the edge of the
site but in the canal
winding whole
training circle
and gradually encroaching onto the edge
of the collection of
to be done
okay
i don't think picking up on one of the
comments essentially
by the recommendations from the
neighbours was regarding uh
what i picked out was has the scientists
have been optimized or maximized
is
without restoration mentioned they
didn't want to
we're all in fact about the scientific
networks to be able to do that
through that a little bit
that affects the layout
again
[Music]
is
[Music]
or to
images
much
is
which is
um
[Music]
um
with the exceptions
[Music]
um
[Music]
take
is
yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you have seen some practice synthesis
throughout these matches and residents
so that's why that one has created
it's not just like engagement
but it's actually it's not reference
connections
thank you
so in regards to that first item on the
objectives they don't have any other
particular functions
or identity
characters
policies
in this case we consider the effect the
effect on character setting uh and
highway safety for the most important
facts in determining an appropriate
density so it was appropriate
it wasn't about maximizing and
optimizing and there's uh there's plenty
in our submission there at six point two
and six point three without the reading
out
sure you've got that down
which talks about
not wanting to maximize if it's optimism
sorry
i'm not searched
it says it does not set an optimum
density
either it has no optimum density or
maximum its main aim is to achieve an
appropriate density to take into account
the circumstances
talking about the density levels
the red approximate was landed about
quite a lot at the early stages
uh and around a number of 30 houses
and approximate that i understand that
is a regularly accepted number is 10
and to go to 50 from 30 is not 10
also the other gentleman said that the
site had been increased by a nominal
amount that is another
word that is non-defined
in value
nominal
by statistics is what is a stated number
which can be anything that anyone
chooses
going to be considered when we're
thinking
let's have a short break 15 minutes
[Music]
yes
so we break that down into two sort of
distinct parts if you like the capacity
of the junction of primrose then
sheffield lane and then if you like more
on premium
i think
application where capacity is
um
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
um
site
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
acceptable
circumstance
of any actions that might alleviate the
current problems
might trigger
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
units on the top
[Music]
the number of properties it just should
i think also include the number
properties
closed as well so just did the 37
that was included
so
that then leads to the density of the
proposal website if there are only 37
existing properties and we already have
problems accessing and parking because
of the school drop off
what's going to happen with 50
properties
extra vehicles and four or five-based
properties
but i think it's an important statement
but there's a point made about the
proximity of the schools from both sides
uh and suggests it's within comfortable
walking distance but i would ask you to
take things with your nurse my
experience driving that comparison
will often tend to drive
and i would agree with that i i know
people who live at the bottom of the
hill and on roads just off the bottom of
the hill they drive up i'll come from
rose lane and close
to take their children they will not
walk up the hill
that that is the current practical
position that we're faced with
[Music]
five days ago that they issued fines on
oakland and scheduled by those junior
schools to park these enforcement issues
and the civil enforcement awards were
involved in that
yes from a safety point of view anything
onto sheffield rules of increased
uh traffic that will generate from any
number whether it be 30 or 50 or
unlatched development
executions
going to be very difficult because of
the
volume of traffic that is already on
there
the number of vehicles that are possible
to be included in the new development
would actually require traffic lights on
that country for everybody to proceed
safely if not it's a danger and will be
an accident waiting to be
yes
i'm a resident of primrose
class
since 1987.
one of the issues that came up back on
is 1994 when primo's close was built
the application was for 30 houses
planning authority whether informally or
former i'm not sure they've declined
that saying that primrose land wouldn't
cold
that was in 1984
15 houses were built in those 12
planning committee at that time
that
the force of israel
said from those way i've reached its
vehicle
capacity use in the uk as well 400 since
1984
so that's sent
to the use of from roseland
which is evidenced by the residents who
used to have no vehicles
now on two and three
the only access along primrose lane
is is possible by residents parking 50
on the footpath
50 on the road
if they got
awkward
or
civil enforcement decided to enforce the
legal rules of parking on footpaths
nobody would get along the lane because
the residents will block it
at least six times a year our bin
lorries don't collect the bins on the
allocated day because they can't access
onto the lane
on this proposed development
because the vehicles that want to
deliver the equipment won't get on
because they can't physically fit
this is why we see recovery vehicles
stop where they deliver a vehicle
reverse into the post
where this proposed access is because
they couldn't turn around
and he spent the next four hours waiting
for recovery because he damaged his tail
lift
my bus is trying to turn around off the
main road
i personally
worked on a job running
on
[Music]
[Music]
that's um issues as a resident trying to
get people regularly blocking my drive
by the children around the school
people coming and going if this proposed
development
if it happens i guarantee
people will park on it to take the
children to school and then
it's a knock on effect
if they've improved it by putting an
extra parking shift as you're going
through the site visit as you come up
sheffield road
there's some parking bays on the
left-hand side if you're going up the
hill try it to primrose
they will put them by the council to
alleviate the problem the road was
altered we give some parking
that's still too far from the school for
people to walk when you see them they
all use the lane
and i'm going back to 1984
on that application where the planning
committee said yes 15
then the lane has reached its people
for safety on a regular daily basis
pedestrians and then we knocked down
our vehicles turning into shocking for
primrose lane the question is up right
away enforced by the highway code as of
or
you get the pedestrian jumping out of
the way the car the car drivers want to
get off the main road because certainly
when they're going up the hill as soon
as they decelerate to turn left into the
lane
they run the risk of being tail ended by
somebody behind them what you're also
getting in a daily basis is that vehicle
behind swerving out at the last minute
after vehicles coming down
because they've not realized
the nature of the bend
to stay on the correct side of the road
and we don't bring the speed down
and
i'm
in great favor of houses being born i've
listened to your comments earlier on
about the density and where houses are
looking and the numbers and i'm all in
favor and you as the country needs it
this this has been identified under the
plans but it's a field and it's suitable
to have houses built on it
but i say as a resident and many
residents secure my opinions
is
by all means
that the access to this field
and real favor lane not primrose land
and put a footpath test for people to
walk into the village
along primrose lane but not for vapes
unfortunately what happens if you'll
prove it
is
you won't see
the ksi stats
killed serious injury steps
development and then it's too late
can i just kind of [ __ ]
gentlemen
right i can speak from experience with
uh developments like this
and the
vehicles that are needed
to access and produce the development
the large vehicles
uh
but have difficulty getting around with
existing
convictions for cars for the local
residents
cars being damaged by the heavy vehicles
and the developers probably not talking
aging
from the damage
what happens then after that is that
you can think that with modern
uh situation is that the estates were
not built for the volume of vehicles
that are available to us all today
so we're all having problems departing
or running
the gentleman has worked out the turning
circle stadium for various parts they
stated those doesn't say what vehicle it
is that's going to talk
to do the turning but there are
regulations that cover them when you get
to there and you get the new development
in they go out to the window because
real life from what appears on the
drawing don't always match up
which is the fact that theoretically
these things work all right he's spoken
of five bedroom houses think in the
future a family
children
in the house five
five cars bird rolling
possibility it happens up and down me my
son has more than five
which parts up the road most of the time
so that's all right you add those into
the mix that we've got now
then roll each side will not accommodate
that number of vehicles
and onto that people having family games
christmas time whatever and visitors and
in the number of cars that come in
the roads currently will not accept that
number of vehicles so
i would suggest that it can't be
achieved and it shouldn't be what's the
fight the list that cannot be
you know where are the people who want
to get to the canal going too far
to check
so i would suggest that the traffic
alone would preclude the fact that this
development is not equipped
thank you very much
thank you um but this might be an ideal
time to follow from what the gentleman
said here about
[Music]
the other access road in appendix 3
that submission uh
and this is the local plantation
statement it says that the council on
the landowner has signed a statement of
common ground between the 30 homes is
justified
then goes to on to say on page 52 of the
local planning statement there are no no
highway objections in principle to the
scheme
this gives you an idea in play with how
the district council then viewed
this development in this piece of land
and some conditions are attached to the
motion in the interest of highway safety
however the permission includes a
provision of a new access rule across
third party land which mentioned which
will need to be acquired by the
developer to ensure that the housing
area the site agencies assured the
council this is progressing well i'm not
the constitutional development
administrator this is a short time ago
but it just gives you an idea if
you like what the council is you can't
say the whole council because the board
council didn't say but what the
council's
developing the local plan were thinking
at the time there was a thought to
development of this area there was a
thought to 30 houses so at that very
time there was also we were thinking
about highway safety and that's why the
time was mentioned then the local plant
hearing
about that uh that
new access field so we knew about it
then
hello i just want to say like from
personal experience and we've got
daughters in a wheelchair we can't go on
the pavement on the corner with all the
cars parked on the pavement i have to go
into the road if the car is on the road
then the cars can't come past
it's like and i've been i've been in a
wheelchair recently and i've found that
and also parents with push chairs
they've got to go onto the road it's
very dangerous
thank you um i'm actually on rotherham
world and i appreciate what everybody
here says they access
uh on and off primrose is atrocious as
it is now and of course as you'll see
when you do a slight visit
uh coming from out of the village it's
at the top of the hill
there's a curve
so people are going to give us a bit of
a
airspeed which a lot do
have not much chance of seeing that
somebody's halfway out of uh
you know out of primrose road
so trim rose is just not suitable for
any extra traffic in and out of it
there is the mention of
the other road through other wood etc
which i live on
that's virtually at its capacity now
so if it starts getting extra traffic
coming out on there
from 50 houses
could we're going to get
gridlocked
that is horrendous uh morning and night
with the rush hour because it's a rat
room from south yorkshire
through kilimanja in northeast
derbyshire to south yorkshire
and vice versa plus
brother road is an a road
and it's the official diversion group
when i have the junction 30 or junction
31 of the motorway closed
so
we've traffic down there all night long
and it's understandable to the time
now
last time we i did a check on that
it took me seven minutes to reverse off
my parking spot at the front of my house
and that was during the normal part of
the day
not just
rush hour
so access in and out of that side
whichever way you want to go with it
anyone else on the current situation
well first of all a question to you you
say you're going to do a site visit
uh i know it's not easy to say when that
might be but could i suggest you i would
do it around about half that date in the
morning
or between three and a half past three
in the afternoon
they are the prime score uh traffic
times
um
i mean the original traffic
for
site visit by people on behalf of
the building
and
it conveniently did it between 11 and 12
uh just as we were coming out of kobe so
a lot of people were still working
obviously just after we got in to
lockdown but they came
hardly any traffic on the road children
were being home in school
that that was the very first one uh they
have subsequently done other um
site visits i i appreciate
when i read the report by mr wilson i
was really through the summary of that
talk
somebody's written a report and done a
site visit who's actually observed
the problems not just the number of
vehicles up and down the main road or
maybe it was coming off
the road you've actually done
a longer period observation of the
practical problems that we face daily
especially in dual school year
and
his data his information and his
photographs in his report of imagination
as you thought
was
as we we experienced it it's not the
video information or the tricks data
that you can
process by algorithms based on
the country-wide situations but
certainly if you were able to
what we records
and and there are
many many many nearnesses either vehicle
to vehicle or vehicles to pedestrians
not just
at that junction of turning from um
sheffield road onto primrose lane and
vice versa but also
primrose main entrepreneurs close when
you're otherwise
doing the u-turn to go back or when
they're coming through around that
corner the speed just to get
a time parking space while there is one
so this looks like the leading edge
about the traffic impact assessment
taken during lockdown that was
considered
that's all we had
any comments on the existing situation
um
[Music]
okay
[Music]
um we look at the existing situation
obviously
myself mr wilson agree
go to
the data set is the question that takes
place and we have analyzed that for
five years assessment which is required
by
the published community council and the
local hardware authority and ideology
historic gardens
that was all done and really high
quality in their own
recorded incidents which is all we have
to learn in terms of evidence um
those may be called against as
[Music]
this and what have you
if that data isn't before reported to
the police we don't have access to that
data
um
i think that's
that's all area in terms of reported
data
i also talk about observations i think
yourself
in terms of the science that you want to
talk to yourself um
being on the highway safety and capacity
i think there are a total of eight
and you mentioned
i think traffic is starting to build up
in one of your photos and then
potentially
um
visibility being restricted and vehicles
from an exit
then on shuttle ground
i think
when we look at sort of assessments
you raise that you know we've done maybe
our
own assessment in terms of capacity
um i think in terms of the proximity of
the school we talk about the existing
situation it's being raised that traffic
blocks back into sort of edge out
it using sort of the school period the
20 mile an hour so it's implemented so
in terms of the safety perspective
you've been arguing that if vehicles are
traveling slower
and they're waiting for the
perspective as opposed to high-speed
traffic and people waiting to exit
and i think one comment was also raised
in the center
the alignment
[Music]
between
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there
is and i think it was about four minutes
when people are blocking the long
shepherd road
what that was from because i don't have
a walk up the road it is due to there is
that eastern hostile backside in
washington so when that bus is pulled
off vehicles are blocking back down
sheffield road which caused the
congestion that i saw
but similarly two bus slots where there
isn't a boston line that was parked in
the carriageway and the moon was way
behind
in terms of existing situations
the police
yes
so
the morning rush hour such as it is
for schools
is roughly
eight until then
when people start arriving in the
afternoon we can start arriving
from half past two and once the the
school uh rush is finished at about four
to four because the
nursery infant and junior school all
have different
uh exit
of very staggering
as soon as that has started to ease a
lot of the small industrial units
ignored uh just behind
the proposed development there are two
different sides
a lot of the workmen there are able to
leave work from half past three or four
o'clock so those eighteen and also from
furniture as has been said kilomarch is
is a wraparound between different parts
of south yorkshire
there is a continuous
stream of
homegoing
industrial unit workers and other people
going just a long section of the road
but checking road is the main artery
through the lower part of
kilometers
and if there are traffic lights if there
are roadworks if there is the extra
traffic coming back because the problem
is on the m1 schedule mode just comes to
a halt
from january until april
there was
one
sequence of building work after another
road repairs for utilities all along
sheffield road up to up to halfway in
south yorkshire
and sometimes it took about 45 minutes
to get spotted
to get up to halfway
or
further beyond
purely because of the volume of traffic
and
the road works well hopefully the
utilities are not going to dig up the
road every day
but it's not an unknown
situation and then when
this has been said when the motorways
got problems we get all of the
diversions
we're not talking rubbish we're not
talking it's helped
[Music]
terms of assessing the suitability of
abduction the potassium exposed
um and i mean that was undertaken june
20 21 surveillance agreed that that time
so we have based on this scale of
development and then we mentioned
potential business assessments based on
the scale of development and how the
authority was
accepting more
um
is
so
in terms of the suggestion of
potentially doing this modeling which i
think was more
um
exiting from red lane but when we go
back to sort of mpdf i would not say
that that would be possible
i know you
being fulfilled
as required
the data that
is gathered
by national agencies etc does not always
reflect real life
and with as with drawings they've been
calculated everything's been done and it
appears right but real life and
calculations and some
considerations don't always match
i would ask one question has a risk
assessment being done of that situation
because that would highlight any
potential hazards that can't be picked
up by statistics
yes
that will then give you
a glimpse into possibilities because
you are examining and looking for
risks and the potential to cause harm
which numbers do not show up to observe
all and like the lady says it would
identify near misses
which are potential to cause harm
following the law
the speed limit 20 miles an hour in that
area
at certain times 20 miles per hour is
still too good
we have to use correct judgment at the
time but everyone does unfortunately but
a nearness is a new miss
anyway
and the numbers not join those only show
where impact has happened you need here
at 20 miles an hour it can be serious
and it is still running
yeah i mean yeah in terms of dogs you
can't cancel
know more than any of the uh
people like ourselves in authority or
whatever who don't live there on the
spot they know more listen to them
unfortunately you're here today to be
able to differently
i will work my way around we've got a
few comments and what we do if we try to
stick to the discussion we're having at
the moment rather than bouncing onto
other points this will help us be able
to keep my notes in order if nothing
else
thank you sir uh
council council highlighting those
safety issues it's not something uh
it's not something we get an awful lot
of uh dr county council don't highlight
many uh
issues uh we don't often as a planning
um
as a planning apology have that much
input from highways it is a constant
complaint by uh complex bank uh
councillors
uh most district councils know that
issue now that itself shouldn't be
relevant to this and i understand that
if that argument's made that it
shouldn't be relevant but we don't get
that input from highways department of
dtt but in practice it does happen and
it happens all the time with nearly
every development anybody on planning
any additional chances and i say
unfortunately as a cancer counselor
so essentially
the encounter capsule perhaps where you
think might be most proactive
they didn't raise an objection to it did
you carry out your own independent
assessment
you were happy with
that yeah you investigated independently
that might be safety issues
especially the diversionary group from
one um
but it also has quite a serious effect
on sheffield road because
uh
two of the routes there's sort of like
three ways they can come off say
200
30
the two of them are restricted
weight wise
so a lot of the heavy goods traffic
uh anything over 87 ton
all comes down to
south yorkshire and comes in to kill a
marsh
uh from south yorkshire and all the way
up sheffield has been booked
for now so that's
an aggravating feature for
uh
[Music]
thanks sir uh it was a
few years ago there was a vehicle fire
and fibregate called out they could only
manage to get to as far as number 15
which is on the corner pretty much close
and using that scenario
the new development couldn't be accessed
certainly the remaining part of primrose
lane
made it pop wouldn't be accessible
especially if there's now a footpath
across the middle of it
also say that a few years ago when
ambulance couldn't get to number four
primrose close they had to stay on
primrose lane and the ambulance people
had to walk around to the touch of the
old lady who was ill
you couldn't get through with that and
also unless you live on there 24 hours a
day seven days a week three to two days
a year you're not going to get
like you're not going to live it as we
live it one observation for observations
whatever over
short lengths of time
do not consider how much you know 24
hours a day
um
is
i mean
[Music]
it is slower vehicles and the gaps
that's created you are still in the line
as i said earlier
[Music]
um in terms of the four-minute
and last but not least i may just
respond to the comments about if there
is parking
enforcement
would be
you were very lucky to see a box
walking up there were two bus stops at
one of them you were very lucky
and
we had uh the bus run
there are several bus routes
but the frequency of the buses has been
reduced over time so it's not well
served by public transport by any means
the roots of
decline or
frequency decline
and
and
but yeah you you were lucky to see above
basically
oh the the two buses that do come
through
on a time table usually come within 10
minutes of each other so that's hard
layer
within
yeah about 10 minutes
and then people who just missed those
have to wait another hour
to get the next one when you're trying
and the bus companies are constantly
revising their schedules
and taking out chunks of
killer marsh
and
public transport is not something to be
promoted widely in a development if
these people
buying these essentially
i wanted to take them with transport
it's just not not a very good option
so
one of the things we discussed that uh
in the planning
uh when transformation was produced was
policy id3 as you know as you're aware
of uh in particular uh item number four
in all cases will only be refused on
transport grants if there's an employee
sexual
when they made that decision this is not
just about whether it's about slow cars
and high impact crashes and uh it's also
highly said it's all about cities and
pedestrians when you've got an increase
in
cars on the road just by slowing things
down doesn't make things safer i know
that many various services myself
you also get
low impact uh crashes which aren't as
devastating as high ones but we do
involve many times cyclists
and pedestrians when you've got extra
cars there you've got extra cars which
may be queuing which people may be
working around and walking around and
walking through the traffic you've also
got cars that are parked on curves
and on the corners now uh a lot of this
is how people behave
we can't always
stop people doing that and the councils
and the police can't stop that but what
we can do is not include
by building this these extra uh houses
in and increasing that uh that weight of
traffic on the road so that weight of
traffic on the road does have an impact
on how we say
not just through cars low impact but
also through pedestrians uh people
pushing plans wheelchairs and mobility
scooters and the rest is obvious so it's
just it's not just the cars
in addition i just like to stop this
same point there we had some video
evidence given yesterday
whatever
if you've got over lunch time you have
the opportunity to see it first as well
and then
always a list that
essentially present new arguments new
arrangements
and costs
more rewards
from what i've had before is
looks like so i hollywood support
there's no big surprise is that it just
comes down to what we're talking about
number of slides
i'm going to set something up after
lunch you'll feel quite satisfied with
that you can come back and go through
that discussion
happy with that
are you able to do that
yeah
okay thank you i'll say we'll have a
break shortly for lunch
um
it is just now 20 past 12. that might be
an opportunity moment
and then the construction traffic
development perhaps after lunch
with some
food here
was saying about the public transport
um
actually i want
we
[Music]
if
is
[Music]
[Music]
right there
no
[Music]
is sheffield road and the access over
there this ball although it's not been
mentioned yet uh primrose lane is not a
straight lane
it does have a slight curve to it before
it gets to the
entrance to the field
and then primrose close goes off
or to the right
these are pictures taken as indicated
23rd of october
2019
um by a resident who lives out number
three three three from those late close
up yeah that's right
[Music]
and you can just see cars parked
the
middle one on the top is a delivery
vehicle uh
i think it would be
it would be
it brought some something to somewhere i
think it was one house further down the
lane having some building work done
or it could have been a vehicle
transportation
um
collecting a small digger sorry
oh that must have been to do with an
initial site assessment
yeah so the road was blocked for 25
minutes
this is an incident november 2020
to uh i guess would be
not
this incident
was uh two parents vehicles
uh at school drop off time in the
morning
uh one reversed and actually hit another
vehicle um
this wouldn't have appeared in any of
the stats
but it's uh two
owners of the two vehicles
and
exchanging details and looking at the
damage that one had caused to the other
vehicle because they didn't realize
that they were about to hit and zapped
is on the junction of primrose lane and
primrose closed
one vehicle had been parked on the bend
and one was reversing off of primrose
clothes onto the lane
but that was the reduction of
the lane and the clothes
that is what it shows uh
last year it's a delivery um
sorry in lorry it was yeah it was a big
he didn't get to pringles gloves that
day he only got to print rose late
so the bins on primrose clothes weren't
empty that day
yeah because it could not go initially
so you'll see even when it's not school
drop off time i mean at seven o'clock
that then laurie had to then reverse
this is
september 21
uh
a bus
i think had got lost
and it actually pulled onto primrose
lane and then
was reversed
it back out and it couldn't do so until
i think a member of the public was
walking down and actually uh directed
him out so it didn't hit any oncoming
traffic
that's not a regular example but it
doesn't happen people and school traffic
are used the entrance to primrose lane
regularly just to do a u-turn after
school pick up
um
if that had been about 10-15 minutes
later
it would have run into the early part of
school
these are
[Music]
delivery issues in january 2022
uh that's these are taken at the
junction of
um
primrose lane and primrose close mostly
uh
it's a vehicle transported uh trying to
reverse down
the unmade up part of primrose lane and
just to the right hand side the top left
picture is the entrance to the field
you will see that
all of the cars parked on the left hand
side are residents vehicles who have to
park there because there's no austrian
parking
so if they're doing then they've got
more than one vehicle and
but i think the vehicle transporter had
come to collect
a vehicle which had had an electrical
fire in the vehicle
and it had
they got the transporter to come and
collect it
um
why they haven't done the second one
i actually witnessed the
um
the aaa or the rac competency to this
vehicle that caught fire i think
electrical problems
and
they then had to call the recovery
vehicles
collect it
the green
uh the castle express
green vehicle
that was someone who had
come onto primrose clothes
and uh delivered
i
believe he was then trying to get down
from the
lane the old nader park
couldn't
and hit the gate post at the entrance to
the field and as
uh ian said
uh damaged the tail end of
the vehicle which meant that he couldn't
do very much with the vehicle and i'm
not sure whether it's in this uh
sequence of pictures but eventually that
the vehicle was moved on to primrose
clothes
so that the vehicle repair
uh people could actually do
uh repairs so they could get back out
and the bottom left although i'm not
sure whether you can see me
that's another delivery vehicle that's
have to park up but in part to probably
occur
so there was enough just enough room for
an ordinary vehicle to go through it
could have been an emergency vehicle or
a
another delivery vehicle nothing would
have got through
the other two
pictures are of similar access where
vehicles do need to get down to the
houses on the unmade part of the lane
if they're having building work done
which several of them
have recently
uh extension work or building up into
the loft space uh they they need
scaffolding up and that
middle right picture is a vehicle
trying to deliver scaffolding poles
um
these are taken
oh
surprisingly
after school rush hour um but um
showing um
the middle at the top
uh several vehicles on uh
primrose lane we made it from just
as you come onto the lane parked upon
the curb
because i believe that some of the
delivered other larger vehicles were
trying to access so they were had to go
on the
actual footpath because there was
nowhere else for them to safely park
and
yeah
some of
most of these are residents vehicles but
some of them would be
visitors
on entrepreneurs
the left-hand picture there
that's how it is on a daily basis and as
the pictures were taken
uh after 10 o'clock in the morning
well
that's not school
traffic by any means
um
again this this would be more i guess at
school
times but the uh vehicle top left
the land rover a range of uh ease
part there
big cop and there's no way pedestrian
let alone the buggy could get there get
between the vehicle and hedge because
there was nowhere else we need to park
and his house is on the lane and he's
parked at the junction of
the lane and the clothes
the bottom left again
the that's the um
it's a freelander that's taken from just
a bit further away
um
on a different day i believe yeah
different day uh he's parked on primrose
clothes there
because there's nowhere else for him to
talk outside his own house
uh the white van i think you're the
delivery van or somebody who works
there called somebody doing something
that would be school related traffic
time lapse and just create free to talk
and you'll see resident vehicles on
drives where possible
these are uh
related to either morning or afternoon
school related traffic yes that bus i'm
not sure whether that's a service bus or
it's a
uh
it's a school bus because
kind of
people's after the
primary school they go to eckington
so they have school buses going through
the village
and also to another school at wales over
in
wales
last one
could you go back one
yes that yeah that's it uh this um
these i think are some of the
photographs
these are some of the photographs i
actually took when julian eisel stood on
the corner of grim rose maine and
sheffield road
counting the number of vehicles
between what was it victory
[Music]
as well and as you saw there was a
former station with traffic
yeah
uh and these are some vehicles that were
then parked on trimmers lane but towards
the end of that time period because a
lot of them had already
gone
[Music]
and
actually taking photographs just to show
the volume of traffic in
that one hour slot in the afternoon
which
thank you for uh
it's not just the traditional uh
drop-off plans and pick-up times uh
for children there there's two schools
we keep going to spawn school there's
two schools there and they have the
breakfast clubs
of the after school clubs uh or
the article
so these so they aren't traditional just
for 20 minutes or a half hour around
those points than much longer so it's
not like it's just a small tendency
or much longer much more of an effect uh
the other point they've mentioned which
i think you've brought up about the bin
laureate because i think but why that
was originally
why include it included a bit more
reversing it's because there's been
constant complaints down there by
revision business and we know this is
the district council of constant
complaints because residents have
haven't had as much accountable black
veterans they answer the reference
collected on many occasions it's not
just one that's true of many occasions
so we've had a lot of that and that
shows that's evidence and the reason why
we can't get down and
the usual schedule times for our things
to be emptied is a monday morning
between seven o'clock and half past
seven before the majority of school
before the school traffic leader gets
slowing
and if they can't get down onto primrose
clothes or primrose malayan made-up
parts especially
between seven o'clock and half past
seven it's because residents
vehicles have to be parked on the road
or apart
and
uh the big lorries or any delivery
vehicles can't get built you would think
that between seven and a half seven in
the morning
there will be fewer vehicles but there's
still resident vehicles who have to park
and just continue
that's why there's a there's been an
understanding of this area for a long
time that councils
[Music]
i think so that's what the bill issue as
well
outlining the background
um
um
construction traffic like the
anticipated construction traffic
to give you a run through of what
nature available
where we'll manage that
[Music]
approximate construction duration period
it's certain types of nature of vehicles
that might be coming down the hours that
might be it yeah we're obviously trying
to avoid the uh the house um
um
and
and then to the proposed sorry so
[Music]
so we have three bins all together and
black then we have recycling and the
green waste so every
interactions like with
the issues that have been raised
looking at chip generation
the junction the operational match which
we have
yeah absolutely i mean as part of the
transport stations that we did the other
days to support the device application
we did the comparison of
accepted thirty
to do a few years of capacity assessment
at the internet so in terms of the sort
of consent and
accepted
allowance for third generation
we were looking at a maximum of 16 to 1
vehicles
so that's
turning into primrose lane and out of
privately
[Music]
[Music]
so we got up to 27 two-way trips in the
pmp and 26 to 8 trips to the amt
so the difference between the accepted
level of 30 volumes and the potential
additional 20s while they use sort of 11
ambition
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
yes
thank you uh just regardless of the
the database the trick status that only
relating to
sort of how to say you're not including
any of the school traffic any of the
things any of the delivery vehicles
my questions related to the proposed
development
and the trips that were generated from
that now in addition to whatever else is
existing already
down here that you wouldn't be doing the
construction vehicles around school time
that's the intention i don't know
so you're right now you're searching
there's a
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
existing traffic flows which is very far
from our higher authority you don't have
growth background growth
and crashes and yet with
is
so
return traffic generation
going back to what you started earlier
[Music]
specifically the size
a bit more
some of those spaces are within garages
yes
could you tell us what provision you
have made
for contractors parking please
well that would come under the
construction management plan
detailed matter
yes
just a question about the garage space
is that
okay properties will have carriages but
how many people actually use their
garages now these days to park cars
because cut vehicles
family vehicles are seem to be ever
increasing in width
so
my car is just the standard
car
my garage is not wide enough
to let it and i'm not i don't have a big
car by any means
um
so how many the garages will actually
accommodate
the
size of vehicles that families will be
using so estate cars people carriers and
all of those they're all kind of
which should accommodate
it just seems that over the time of
various developments
particularly this one and gary just
seems to be a standard whips
vehicles just keep increasing everything
it turns to northeast television
and
submissions
[Music]
my position would very much be
that the additional number of journeys
would be likely to happen
it's obviously subjective about what is
an
unacceptable impact
i
to meet
so i will
the sites and is sites the council was
just promoted besides suitability of the
residential development from the recent
pokemon examination which had been
adopted he made a positive case as to
the sustainability and potentially
inspector
[Music]
any evidence
impact on highway safety
[Music]
exercise here that suggests that
something can be acceptable or not
going back to
what's in there and you look at the
background of the situation
you can't overrule
even with 30 round axes okay
and therefore running
there's no evidence
[Music]
but as i mentioned earlier
that was with the provision of a new
access floor across the third bottom
line it was done with the intention of
that that's what the original intention
was for the chinese
[Music]
it didn't make it into the up to local
standards
that the development of the site
allocation must be supported by
successful access rate otherwise to be
reviewed and if i'm wrong i'd be very
very pleased
can't
does anyone have anything else they want
to raise with me you have to get through
that we have touched i think almost
thing probably labor again if anyone
wants to raise anything else they want
to
go into i'm more than happy to have got
time for it yes i'll take that one
yeah
it's a libra
[Music]
uh
um
yes
the access onto the field which is
proposed across opposite property number
19-21 i think
um
is is just another accident waiting to
happen you will have
two um
two
roads
and going off of primrose lane one being
the existing one at primrose close
and then within a few meters
big access onto
the development onto the field
anybody coming off of primrose clothes
has not only got to look
onto what is left beyond made of parts
in those name but also almost
look back 180 degrees to make sure
there's nothing off coming off of the
access to the phone's development
that will all have the creek
to say the very least
[Music]
where do the people at number 19 and 21
part their cars
because it's going to be a footprint
across to the new development from my
reading of the information
where are they going to carve
they park currently outside their own
ships
yeah i think they're talking in terms of
firstly the proximity of the commerce
primrose close access like yeah so i
think it's about 125 meters well i'm not
i've not changed yeah
it's miserable
so
you have to actually look around the
hedge to actually see what's coming up
you're almost onto primrose lane off of
the close
to look at what's coming off
yeah
can be achieved
that is
properties at least
where are they going to start they have
milwaukee street
parking
unless you're going to give them
dedicated parking spots on the new site
are they on the unadopted
end two properties of the unmade part
sweetness but could we stop the
provisioning
yes
there is
at the moment some some properties
further down primrose lane on the
unadopted part don't have sufficient
parking and they park opposite my house
[Music]
i wouldn't normally do closing
statements better says you were just an
informal hearing however i have a
pleasure to become the two barristers
in perhaps i would be missing a trick if
i didn't accept closing statements from
them
um
[Music]
is
the planning application which was
passed for this property in 2016
which never went ahead
their plan for access onto that field
was not as you've got it in this this
plan it was to go in the gateway
and purchase the end
part of the property number 15 primrose
clothes to make the world well it wasn't
as is
[Music]
i can say
[Music]
the first
[Music]
other matters
okay
in that case we move on to the likes of
conditions and planning obligations
we've touched on them already as i said
before this isn't
suggesting that i have already made a
decision on the appeal or the captain
and seen their case in any way
ordinances go through the conditions
that make them they are in the statement
of common ground
[Music]
i think
although i say the conditions are
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
how
[Music]
preferences
um
[Music]
is
um
is
mitigation
[Music]
um
yeah i think the issue we've got is more
in terms of the longer term retention
maintenance
um
um
[Music]
um
which is to de-risk
applications were made for further
development
when it came
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay
and
i've seen everything i need to see here
before i go out to the side
arrange make some slight business
arrangements
so
my previous concern about doing that by
myself tomorrow morning obviously it's
where all the residents live
[Music]
but not everyone wants to rock up at 7
30 in the morning on the site
[Music]
[Music]
i'll probably not try to do it for the
dash i'll be quite honest i'm quite
happy to rock up tomorrow morning i will
probably do that side visit by myself
so if you do see me wandering around
ignore me
by themselves
[Music]
depending on the weather tonight you
might need one of these
no problem
fine
in that case
once i've heard the closing stage from
both parties
get back we'll do that we'll then go off
we'll have the site visit which case you
are all welcome to follow me around if
you want to i will require someone from
the council someone from
the appellate side to a company
with me
if you're happy
obviously it's private site so you don't
have to
we'll arrange the actual final time to
meet on site once we've actually
finish the closing statements like
closely here and here
uh we'll meet something after the
junction
of the application site and criminals
learn this problem
okay let's have a quick break for 10
minutes
[Music]
so
to the third parties have anything you
would like to add message mistakes
i think i've said all of the things i
really have to say and you've seen the
elements in your pictures on the screen
so yeah we live with those situations
every day
and that's we can exist the volume of
traffic and residents vehicles and
deliveries and refusing
so
vehicles for another 50 properties will
help
residents points of view
ages which waiting as it's all
principled
having policy frameworks and things like
that as well so it's quite important
because it's going to impact a lot more
than just residents in the move
more far reach impacts from the western
virginia
thank you
we want to account
that may be right but we really aren't
talking about apple's we're talking
about 30 properties
uh
or approximately 30 properties
uh going up to 50 it's a nearly 50
increase
but it's actually really more than that
in real terms because the
area of the site has decreased
dramatically
and the independent people they describe
it's normal for that
you will see so when you look at the
state of common ground
so
it's a nearly 50 increase of 30 to 50
but also
and that's really the umbrella
that encompasses all points about
density and sustainability
professional character et cetera
and also as mr rayford said earlier
um we are talking as well about a
development which is next to the cloud
which is effectively supposed to be
centered now by having a hedgerow
and i say it's really a red parrot at
this point too
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um the the issue then of highways
um on policy id3
and
paragraph 2011 of the um
i say the bird is
of highway safety unacceptable obviously
subjective work but it would be very
unpalatable to say
that any real effect on what they're
saying would be acceptable so it's a low
threshold
but even if you are amazed
[Music]
also
and all of this is in the context of
being close to two schools
uh junction with the busy road shepard
road that's an arterial road
and i'll just make reference also said
because i've touched on id3 because i
say the national planning policy
framework will say
paragraph 112 of that again i know so
re-reading of course
considering your decision
but particularly 112 b
which is within this context
applications for development should be
address the needs of people with
disabilities
in relation to almost transport you can
which minimize the scope of conflicts
between clustering and cycles
bus stop nearby
um that's certainly engaged and d
allowing the efficient delivery of goods
to access by service and emergency
vehicles
well again you've seen the post price
from the slides you've seen it because
you've seen low note calls
the big lori having to reverse down
through and again
it's called the elephant in the room
about the site being allocated but in
these apples and oranges there is a real
difference between 30 and 50 houses and
followers i say that the additional 50
in terms
thank you very much
so there are two applications uh before
you the second application was
substantially the same as the first
application the differences amounting to
provision of the junction capacity
assessment and nhs
contribution the applications saw
planning commission 50 dwellings and
associated roads sewers gardens parking
and garages
refusals followed extensive
pre-application consultation by the
appellant with the officers of the
council and other stakeholders the
offense addressed the issues raised by
officers
and this resulted in a favorable
recommendation from officers for both
applications
the decision of the members of the bank
committee to overturn the
recommendations of their
disappointing
not least because the professional view
represented by austin was the
combination of close engagement with the
council and no substantive concerns were
raised by statutory consultants
nevertheless the planning committee
determined that permission should be
refused to respect the vote application
is for related to reasons for refusal
those reasons are essentially the same
my submission to you so
we reached those uh
reasons for refusal other than the
reception second application there is no
mention of the capacity assessment as
the defense has provided one and the
references are updated to the freshly
adopted local plan
on behalf of the opponents
you've heard sir from distractor and
planner masters this neural transfer
national installer architectural map
given with careful consultation on the
attention party account consultants and
capital officers advancing teams it's
unsurprising for the defense case for
room for the officer's reports
he's at the proposed development course
for the defense plan and will deliver
housing from an alligator to the front
in the sustainable sentence
their walls controversy is to the
meaning of policy lc1 the submission i
made in the hearing
certainly there's no mechanism for
refusal within it
thirdly approximate is neither ceiling
nor floor
it means around that number
and the relevant external paragraphs of
a lotus plan paragraph 51
makes no mention of the allocated carbon
cycle constrained by greenfield nature
nor sustainability concerns indeed it
notes that it has outlined banks
dependent submission is the proposed
development therefore
in closing the council raises
the fact that despite the smaller area
for proposed development
the council's case in the case of the
interests of parties has been exploited
30 dwellings on this site is
approximately 13.1 units per hectare
against a policy requirement and dps
guidance the density should be optimized
the proposed development is 21.93 units
per hectare
so in my respectful submission the only
non-compliance with the development plan
i would accept is in the opposite
direction to that advocated by the
council and interested parties given the
policy requirements
is 30-50 units per hectare
the reason why the proposed development
to the nest is decided to take account
of the special characteristics of the
allocation site
given the officer's reports and the
consulting responses
you sir can be sure that the only
potential planning actions which are
allegedly terrorized many permissions
are those contained within reasons for
refusing
briefly to the council's check
in circumstances where decisions have
been taken contrary to the advice from
obviously the teasing funds for the
council to produce evidence and
justification for those machines
the council has to explain what the
refusal of permission was justified
the council's evidence provided only
very limited kind of career assessment
in support of the reason for refusal
matters of disagreement between the
parties who might submission a strategy
set out for paragraph 10 for the state
of the common grounds and the event
consists that it's provided a
comprehensive response to those issues
never identified
for people like said in adherence the
difficulty the council faces
is that the site is an animated type
the council had just promoted the fight
suitability for the dead from the
veterans in the recent open plan for
examination
it made a positive caters for
sustainability and potential impacts for
the local inspector
in those circumstances the council has
not explained
firstly
why residential development of a
greenfield site which has been allocated
for residential development is
unacceptable i made this point
frequently during the course of the
hearing year didn't appear to be
enlisted by the council
like the that element of the meeting for
refusal relations
is unsustainable
secondly
it's still not clear to you
how residential development is
detrimental to the character of the area
in the context of site
thirdly
it's unclear how the proposed
development could lead to unacceptable
impact on sustainability and adverse
effects on the character of the area in
circumstances where the council's case
must be that twenty nest dwellings would
be acceptable such that the council was
able to promote the site adaptation
in the local plants
inspector
would have noted that in response to
these fundamentalist points the
council's focus was on points of
detailed design
which were not in the reason for refusal
nor raised by any statutory community
canvassed earlier
lastly white vehicle movements of 50
dwellings would be severely harmful to
and have an unsuccessful impact on
highway safety
when that amounts to
agreed 11 trips generated
whereas the vehicle movements of 30
drone
would not be harmful let alone severely
harmful because unacceptable impacts on
public safety such as the council where
they would promote the psychiatrist
it's also still a lot clearer how
character did allocate it is adversely
affected by the proposed development in
a way that it would not be
where it develops under the allocation
in the local plan
notably the council does not provide a
heritage landscape
design
landscape architect evidence
and did not appear to take issue with
for example development balance heritage
statement
almost evolved description of how and
why the proposed development was planned
particularly the removal of the hse
constraints on the staff which the most
natural commission is an explanation for
why this fight approved
in relation to the highways reason for
refusal
the council's case is that the
development would be severely haunted
the highway safety that's what it says
in the region's refusal
but it says in the state of the case the
policy test is lower bar of acceptable
impacts
however whichever way the council seeks
to make the point the simple fact is
that the evidence before the hearing
from the council such as the deal
extraordinarily
based
instead what the council seeks to do is
that yeah
to provide
[Music]
the real question i expect permission
nor does the council address the
critical activist submission so the
highways authority has said that it has
no consensus four times
i threw down the important lessons
logged up there here
i made clear that the position of the
appellate course
is the additional 20 houses that you sir
should be concerned with
that appeared not to be resisted and
respectfully
picked up
points were raised in respect to the
local planning termination and
statements
but those concerns did not make it into
the adopted labor plan which was found
to be sound
the simple point there is that the
appeal must be decided in accordance
with the development plan
unless material considerations indicated
no other material considerations have
been reckoned an sac
or borrower council's desired position
do not fall off the vote
in the round these are appeals
containing proposed residential vessels
which is supported by officers presented
by this statutory council
and which complies with the development
fund as well as in
etf
it provides high quality considered
housing proposals as
is
gosh
is everybody happy there
nothing else to say no burning desires
thank you very much on the sites about
say
in the morning
thank you very much for assistance
you